blood clots began to form internal
organs begin to fail and in a matter of
days the body hemorrhages and dies
terrors all caused by a nightmare come
to life
Ebola is a rare but extremely dangerous
disease it's classified as one of the
most lethal diseases on the planet with
a fatality rate of up to 90% Ebola is
caused by six species of virus with four
known to cause sickness in humans and
each is named after the locations of
their outbreaks the first known species
was a year Ebola virus discovered in
1976 near Zaheer's Ebola River a river
faded to become the namesake of all
Ebola viruses like all viruses Ebola
viruses infect and feed off of their
hosts starting on a microscopic level
the viruses which are string like
structures contain genetic information
in the form of ribonucleic acid or RNA
encasing the RNA are layers of proteins
the proteins on the outermost layer are
highly versatile capable of changing
shape and binding to different types of
cells within a host when binding occurs
the Ebola virus fuses with a host cell
allowing the viruses RNA to infiltrate
the cell and to replicate the virus from
within this infection quickly spreads to
countless cells throughout the body
resulting in some of the most terrifying
symptoms known to man within eight to
ten days those infected by the Ebola
virus may experience symptoms
drastically ranging in severity from
fevers to diarrhea and vomiting to
internal and external bleeding often
from the
while outbreaks had been caused by
multiple species of Ebola virus the
strain with the highest fatality rate
was the first to be discovered
Zaire Ebola virus in 2014 it caused the
most severe outbreak in history sweeping
through western Africa and resulting in
over 11,000 deaths more than all earlier
Ebola outbreaks put together at this
point no cure for Ebola exists plus the
communities most likely to be affected
do not have sufficient access to health
care in the meantime international
efforts are being made to develop and
test vaccines that could potentially
stop the disease once and for all
[Music]